they continue firing
missiles all over the territory of
ukraine they keep in siege according to
our information about 120 000 people
only in marijuana crimes that are
happening in mariupol are much more
awful and large scale than in barodanka
i am convinced that is our joint efforts
we will be able to inflict liability on
all those guilty and i do
assure you that we will find everybody
well we can talk now the sky is jason
farrell who is in odessa in the south of
ukraine and jason we've seen all sorts
of
failed deals and tentative agreements
come and go in mario poll is this one
does this one have a chance of working
do you think
[Applause]
well there have been prisoner exchanges
before there's been five prisoner
exchanges during the course of this
conflict only one yesterday in which 76
ukrainians were returned so zielinski's
perhaps thinking that this is something
that the russians might be up for they
might agree if they can get some of
their own troops back because this these
are almost prisoners of war they are
select effectively surrounded it's
impossible for them to get out we heard
from one of the commanders in a video uh
earlier saying that um they're
outnumbered ten to one they have 500
wounded they have over a thousand
civilians there i've spoken to the wife
of one of the people who is one of the
fighters there who says that the
conditions are appalling uh they haven't
eaten for the the this entire time they
have have no access to water no access
to food so they are in a dire situation
and of course as well they will be
running out of ammunition they've got no
way of restocking or resupplying and
they are being consistently pummeled and
blasted one of the explosions reported
this morning
was heard a hundred kilometers away now
my colleague mark stone has actually
managed to be able to get some questions
to one of the commanders who is inside
that steel works which has been
surrounded let's have a listen to what
he's had to say
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well meanwhile in the donbass that push
is gathering pace and the russian
military say that they have hit over a
thousand targets along a 300 mile front
line
in that region
and we've also had a development this
afternoon because as you know president
zielenski has been asking the west to
continue to resupply and restock uh
weapons for ukraine and perhaps uh in in
an answer to that so vladimir putin has
uh tested a missile it is an
intercontinental ballistic missile that
was fired across from the north west of
north west of russia all the way over to
kamchatka in the east that is uh 6 000
kilometers it actually goes through um
11 different time zones so a
an enormous distance that it travels and
really trying to flex his muscles and
send a message out to the west that he
has a capability to attack other powers
if they want to get involved in this war